but i got a tv show
when i got 5 000 subscribers on youtube
incredible like people think you have to
go get two yeah a tv show my paycheck
says disney on it right
which is i'm on disney's payroll because
i had 5 000 subscribers and i was just
telling a story about my business people
if you guys are out there and you're not
turning the camera on and you're not
building your personal brand
i would say how many
successful youtubers or how many
successful content creators are in your
immediate social network the answer is
probably zero and you guys aren't
spending time getting to know people in
facebook groups or spending time getting
to know people in the youtube comments
on you know think media's youtube
channel that's where i would go welcome
to the think media podcast my name is
heather torres your host of this show
where we want to help you build your
influence on youtube and then turn that
influence into a high impact and a high
profit online business and if you're
brand new to this show we want to
welcome you and encourage you to click
subscribe wherever you are receiving
this content we give you a brand new
episode here on the podcast every single
tuesday for our
tuesday ritual so if you would like to
be a part of that make sure you're
subscribed wherever you like to listen
well today i'm excited because we are in
a series right now of having amazing
entrepreneurs on the show that are going
deeper into things like how to make
money using your brand personal branding
how to actually do content and so much
more and today we have none other than
my friend pace morby now i'll get into a
little bit more about what this episode
is but i want to let you know that if
you've not yet taken our free youtube
class then your next step will be to
head over to
thinkmasterclass.com every single one of
our episodes is brought to you by one of
our classes and this is a no miss class
you're going to be learning the secrets
to youtube success what's working right
now on youtube as more and more people
are coming online to grow their brands
grow their businesses with youtube and
your exact next step for how you can
dominate this next year using your
influence so go to
thinkmasterclass.com if you have not yet
taken that class now today's episode is
all about personal branding we're diving
into how an ordinary entrepreneur
actually someone who is kind of scared
of getting on camera has blown up and
has created one of the largest creative
financing brands on youtube none other
than pace morby is on our show today
pace is a sub to storyteller he's an
entrepreneur real estate investor
business strategist and influencer in
2022 pace acquired over 32 million
dollars worth of asset properties in the
united states he's actually the host of
triple digit flip on a e he's a real
estate investor with over 900 doors and
he has one of the largest creative
financing brands to date he has almost
10 million views on his youtube channel
and he dives into so much on this
podcast that you're going to want to
make sure you lean in we're talking all
about how to actually start your
personal brand online what type of team
you should build around yourself and
some of the mistakes he sees
entrepreneurs making when they come on
youtube so grab your pen and paper or
your notes app on your iphone and let's
jump into today's featured conversation
[Music]
pace i am beyond excited to have you i'm
way more excited i i thought i was gonna
have sean cannell on here and i'm so
glad it's heather so much i love you so
much more i mean sean's cool but you're
freaking way better so good to see you
this is literally why i wanted to have
you on you're like my you're like you're
like you want to talk about like hype
person like can i just have you always
around me all the time i'm that guy i'm
not all the things um pace you are an
extraordinary entrepreneur i'm excited
to have you on the podcast today we're
going to dive into personal brands
because i know that this is something
you personally have been developing over
the last several years and i think you
bring so much value to this conversation
especially for other entrepreneurs that
are like you in all different industries
you happen to be dominating in the real
estate investment space um and really
growing companies that way uh even into
you know modern day television you are a
star on an a e show and so you're really
um i think you have mastered the
personal brand when it comes to the
things that people really strive for but
i want to pull this back a little bit
and really talk about the person pace
morby uh you know how did you even get
into developing a personal brand i know
that you had been you know working in
the real estate space before flipping
homes and you know picking up a camera
and starting to share your life what was
that like walk me through that journey i
think i struggled just as much as
anybody else in that realm by the way
because i i grew up blue collar and a
lot of your
you know most people grow up blue collar
like their parents are hard working
maybe their dad or their mom are in the
trades um and you grow up
never wanting to be on camera because
you don't want the highlight on you and
you're like oh you know i don't want
anybody ever think that i think i'm
better than anybody else and you start
creating this like imposter syndrome
you know i'm afraid of looking like i'm
a big shot
right because like you come from a town
and your friends are like oh you think
you're better than us or you think this
my wife i remember um
we went to
uh new mexico
or around her family and her family
hears that she gets her real estate
license right it just takes three weeks
and like 1200 bucks it's not like she
got a doctorate right that took like 12
years and one of her cousins says oh you
think you're better than us now
right it's like that i came from that
atmosphere and so for me
overcoming that was really challenging
and i'm sure you have a lot of audience
members that are like oh my gosh turning
the camera on me i don't i you know what
people are going to think of me and all
that kind of stuff guys everybody deals
with that i promise
um so i had that too but what i realized
is that um
i had a lot of fun doing it so i picked
up instagram my first instagram post was
literally you can go back all the way
through my instagram post and i just
looked at instagram as a journal of my
day that was it i was like wow i don't
like taking photos and uploading them to
a computer but instagram has this really
cool way of just harnessing your photos
and i can go back and look at them or it
reminds you of something you posted a
year ago
and so i started looking at at a journal
as a journal
and at the time i was a contractor
surprise surprise i grew up in a blue
collar contractor house and i became a
blue collar contractor
and i started using before and after
photos of like backsplashes and kitchens
and stuff like that and all of a sudden
my business started popping off and i
had no idea why
and then people would say well yeah i i
saw your thing on instagram i'm like
what
what i'm like using this thing as a
journal to just document my my story
and because it wasn't intentional for me
to like go out and use it as a marketing
mechanism i don't think i overthought it
i just did it because it was fun
and it showed up on my instagram that
way and it conveyed that way and so
people wanted to do business with me in
some weird way i
didn't have to ever overthink it but if
i if i was intending to go create a
personal brand i would have over thought
it i could tell you that 100 times yeah
so you started posting those before and
after photos which i mean coming from a
marketer standpoint i'm like genius
that's exactly what you should do it
shouldn't be about the food you're
eating it should be up about the product
you're selling right so uh you did that
just out of intuition walk me through
what that looked like from now you're
taking photos on instagram to now pace
you have a youtube channel with over 8
million views it's the number one
youtube channel right now uh for
creative finance and you really are
establishing yourself as an industry
go-to because of the personal brand that
you've built so walk me through the
stage of i'm posting photos to i've now
built this youtube studio i'm creating
content all the time what was that
journey like
uh that journey was a couple of years um
and i can tell you think media was a
huge part of it this is why like you got
i'm a huge fan of both of you guys
um and i told you this in front of sean
cannell when i first met you i go look
sean's cool but heather's way cooler
just fyi but you guys were a big part of
that journey for me um because nobody
does what you guys do on youtube where
you're like yo let's get you a personal
brand let's use video and youtube as a
way to leverage your way into it i went
the wrong way
i went instagram facebook and other
things before i started youtube and when
i realized and this is something sean
cannell said on your guys's channel a
couple years ago he said youtube is a
search engine
and it's the really the only thing
that's evergreen somebody's going to
google
you know how to get started in real
estate it's not going to pull up an
instagram post you did four years ago
but it will pull up a youtube video you
did 10 years ago right
so um for me
when i started posting i got a phone
call from a company this is now 10 years
ago okay
my personal brand didn't really kick in
until i'd say five years ago
um and it was just me making mistakes
for a long time
and not even being intentional about it
but i got a call from a company called
open door
open door is a massive real estate
investment company and they hired me as
a contractor to do their renovations
and they found me on instagram and i was
like oh my gosh there's something to
this
in 2015 do you mind if i brag a little
bit because i'm here for it
in 2015 i made my first million dollars
take home like million dollars and i was
like i literally did that because of
instagram
holy moly like i didn't have to spend
any ad dollars i didn't have to go out
and hobnob and schmooze and do all the
things and network i literally just used
personal brand and at that point i was
like double down double down double down
so i started posting more intentionally
i started telling more stories and the
stories i really thought about were
you know stories i wanted to tell so i
could
genuinely attract my own tribe instead
of trying to attract people that i
didn't want in my world
somebody told me um
they said your vibe attracts your tribe
and so i was very intentional like i
just want to put my vibe out there be
authentically who i am because then it
brings the people who are very similar
to me right like
married men married couples people with
kids you know that's my tribe people
that genuine like want to have a family
and you know there's single people here
i'm not alienating you but it's like
those are things that are important the
family was really important to me it
still is obviously but i wanted to
attract those people so i started
telling more stories about my kids
telling more stories about trips i was
going on and then i started telling
stories about my workers and their
families
and people fell in love with my business
because they looked at it like a sitcom
with additional characters
and all of a sudden it was just like it
went crazy i had open doors a client
then i got zillow as a client and then i
got offer pad as a client and i was like
oh my gosh my business was just blowing
up
then i saw on think media that youtube
was like the way to go so i got
intentional about youtube
and um
i don't want to i don't even want to
like go into this but it is i do i will
go into it but i got a tv show
when i got 5 000 subscribers on youtube
it's incredible like people think you
have to go get
a tv show on my paycheck says disney on
it right
which is i'm on disney's payroll because
i had 5 000 subscribers and i was just
telling a story about my business
and that all just transpired without me
without me really having
a ton of intention behind it other than
i just want to tell stories about what
i'm doing and see if it can pull people
into my businesses
um you guys helped me through the
youtube journey
um like we've done your guys's trainings
i even have hired some people on your
team to do some one-on-ones with people
on my team which has been epic and
amazing
and um
for me i realized like if i could go
back in a time machine i would have
started youtube way earlier
youtube is way more important in my
opinion than anything else because like
tick tock very surface level instagram
very service level facebook a little bit
maybe a little bit deeper but youtube oh
my gosh that's where people marry you
they marry your brand they like really
get into your world
and i i sure as heck wish i started
youtube like three years prior i i would
have made millions and millions and
millions of dollars more if i had just
started youtube faster
wow that's incredible and you are
speaking my language too because to me
when i think about all the time we could
spend on all the different platforms i'm
like i want to be on the one that's
going to give me the best return on my
investment and really youtube is that
yes i think you should do video
everywhere right garyvee just spoke at
our conference and he was like it's not
or it's and but i think if you're going
to invest your time and really serve
people on a deeper level youtube is
where you can do that now i want to go
into um you know you've talked in the
past about uh some of your tips when it
comes to developing out your personal
brand one of the things that i just so
admire about what youtubepace is that um
you you really are for the audience and
when i'm coaching different content
creators when i'm seeing different
people out there i'm like man your
content is so
selfish right it's all about you and
that's different than telling a story
but it really is serving you as the
content creator and one of the tips that
you have is to actually be selfless and
care about everyone can you talk about
what go
giverness means
yeah i actually the the book i have
right here
um
sitting on my table is the go giver by
um bob good old bob
amazing book if you guys have not read
the go giver um i'm an i'm a pisces so i
naturally just want to solve everybody's
problems all the time it's just
something else i guess i was born with
so when you tell me a problem i
immediately forget about all my problems
and all i want to do is solve your
problem so it's kind of an addiction for
me
um so being a go giver here's what
happens when you just give and give and
give and give gary vee talks about this
all the time
people want to do business with you
right it cuts away all the crap
like
we have all seen the people or at least
in my in my real estate world there's so
many influencers that are just out to
like sell a course
whereas in um
if you're giving and giving and giving
to people like right now i'm doing a
two-week free challenge with people four
hours every day where i'm just solving
their problems calling their sellers
locking up deals for them and doing
things for their real estate business
that are
students of mine yes non-students of
mine yes people have never even gotten
into real estate yes and just giving
that time frame to them
this lady laura smith comes in today
this just happened less than an hour ago
as we were wrapping up the four hour
challenge we did today
and she says pace you've never met me
but i've paid for course after course
after course and nobody has cared about
me as an individual as you have and i
have never paid you a penny
and i said
great like if everybody could say that
about me and i could die then i could
die happy like that's all i really
really want i just want to change
people's lives and where that comes from
is yes i'm a pisces
but also
when i was starting out
i felt like i was lost and i didn't have
a path to follow and i felt like if i
just had somebody grab me by the hand
and tell me take this step next and then
take this step next and yes you're still
on the path and yes everything's fine
and here's the light here's the here's
where to look in the dark corners
i would have been so much further ahead
and so i became obsessed with doing that
for other people whether it's paid or
free
and that actually is what got us the tv
show
what got us the tv show is i did a
youtube video
talking about not competing with people
in your local market but collaborating
with your your fellow competitors
and amy picked that up on my youtube
video and they're like this is what tv
needs this is what everybody in the
world needs is less competition way more
collaboration
and we ended up um
getting a tv show from having that exact
spirit in our our videos
that's just amazing to me because you
know when you think about personal brand
you're thinking okay i need to grow me
but actually what it is it's about being
selfless and it's about sharing as much
as you can right moving the free line is
what we talk about here at think media
and just really trying to help people if
you're just out there to really help uh
that's where you can really start to see
the reciprocity in that you know here at
think media too we say we uh we were on
a goal to get 10 000 people to be full
time and we were talking to someone
who's an industry expert and we told
them that's our goal and they're like oh
you've already done that like oh i was
just thinking there's no way you haven't
done that yeah and we were like yeah
because to us we just want to give away
as much as we can to help people move
forward so i love that that is i love
that i love that line you just laid um
moving the free line
i don't think a lot of people will
understand that entirely like in in my
line of work like in the real estate
world
people have these like
you know free lead gen things and you
know sign up for this and sign up for
that and it seems free and then
immediately they're like punching people
in the face with some ten thousand
dollar thing
in fact
there's people in my industry that are
charging sixty to a hundred thousand
dollars for like real estate education
and their education is not even
one-tenth of what i give away for free
that's what you mean by pushing the free
line it's like how do you
and so what do you like how do you guys
define that you're just trying to change
the industry as a whole of saying
all of this stuff should be free
there should be no this line shouldn't
be here it should be way way over here
and giving way more than what people
expect is that what you're saying yeah
exactly and you know even into our paid
programs into our coaching that becomes
more personalized we're taking you from
like point a
all the way to point z and having it in
that order with multiple things that you
need a lot of people think oh i'm gonna
buy courses and teach me how to do
something which it should but when you
are going into even
into changing your life you have to
change your mindset and so a lot of
times people don't even realize that
when you're when you are in think
media's world a lot of things we're
teaching you on youtube is the like how
to do it like you need this camera and
this thing and this thing but then
you've got it all set up and you're not
pressing record why well that's when you
go deeper with us and i can really help
you overcome so good
right and so it's that idea of like move
the free line to the point where if
someone got massive success without ever
paying you you'd be happy and that's
what i want because i believe that when
you do that especially in your personal
brand it's your reputation and i don't
want to be known as someone who won't
help you i want to be known as someone
that you can always go to to get help is
it weird to say that you and sean
cannell are one of the reasons why i
have a tv show
i mean i will take a cut if that's what
you're offering oh you don't want to cut
up that paycheck that paycheck is a joke
but you like genuinely
there's so many times where you guys um
have done videos talking about the
mindset of pressing record and so if you
don't mind i i could i'd love to tell a
little story i'm here for stories you
are an absolute amazing storyteller so
go ahead facebook okay cool so i my one
of my biggest heroes his name is robert
g allen and he wrote a book back in the
80s called
nothing down meaning he taught people
through a book how to buy houses with no
down payment okay
okay cool that's not what the story is
about but what happened is he releases
this book it gets critical acclaim
people are super happy about it and the
la times this is like 1987. okay
la times
runs an article that says this guy's a
fraud and we're calling him out and
there's no way that this guy can do this
okay
so robert g allen's publicist
then says robert i i think you stay away
from this we don't i don't think we do
anything but just leave it alone and
robert g allen says
no i want to accept their challenge
and i want to make it public
so he accepts their challenge and here's
what their challenge was their challenge
was
we will give you 72 hours
to go to a city of our choice with a
hundred dollars in your pocket for food
and hotel
basically live in the brick bricken
streets
and you show us how you're gonna go buy
a house with nothing down okay
i'm like
dang really like that's pretty amazing
for you to take that challenge on so
here's what he does he flies into la
which is obviously where the l.a times
is
they couple him with a reporter they
drive him to the airport they fly right
when he's loading the plane he goes oh
wow we're going to san francisco
california holy moly
so they fly him and the reporter to to
san francisco they drive to downtown and
they drop him off in downtown san
francisco
here's your hundred dollars go to work
reporters standing there like oh i can't
freaking wait for you to fail this is so
great
so he goes over to a hot dog stand
buys a hot dog in a soda gets basically
99 back but he asks for a roll of dimes
because this is back when dropping a
dime was literal right you're dropping a
dime so he goes over to a payphone opens
up the
yellow pages and he starts calling local
real estate agents
just starts cold calling
all right cool i guess this is what's
going on the reporter's thinking so
robert bleeds through 10 bucks really
fast makes 100 calls
and he gets a little bit of traction
like real estate agents like i don't
have anything now but i'll let you know
blah blah blah
so robert goes holy moly i'm going
through money and it's starting to get
dark i better head to a hotel so he
heads to a hotel they find something in
like the cheap part of town 17 a night
he makes the reporter pay for the other
um half of it so he's you know both are
8.50 out of pocket
and so what does he start do using is
the telephone inside the hotel and he's
like holy crap i should have used this
way faster way sooner i wouldn't have
gone through my 10 bucks
so he's making calls he gets a return
call at 9 30 at night from a real estate
agent says hey
um i got your message robert that said
hey you're new in town and you're
looking to buy a piece of property for
nothing down and i actually have a
seller that will sell you two properties
with nothing down tomorrow come meet us
over at his house
the reporter is like laughing at this at
this point because he's laying in the
bed next to robert and he says hey um
dude there's no way you didn't use some
sort of code or you called somebody you
used words to like entice this thing
going on there's no way you're not lying
about this there's no way this is
happening
so robert goes all right well we'll see
tomorrow so they go to the appointment
they meet the seller and the agent sure
enough he buys two houses with nothing
down from an agent and a a seller the
eight the the reporter goes through a
30-minute interview and he's like are
you real or you do know robert gial and
they go through all the things and he
goes sure enough dude holy crap you did
this you just bought two houses in like
20 hours
with nothing down this is insane i guess
let's go let's let's go back to la i'm
ready to write the article this was
crazy
and robert says
i still have 54 hours
and he goes and buys five more pieces of
real estate with nothing down in 72
hours
wow okay there's a point to this
and here's what happens
they he buys seven houses with nothing
down in 72 hours with a hundred dollars
in his pocket with a reporter by his
side to prove that this is possible to
do all these things and show people this
is exactly how to do it step by step by
step by step
so
they go back to la he writes a report it
goes up in the la times nationwide and
it says
real estate investor
takes on the la times and wins
and robert g allen becomes this the
second most popular person in the entire
like mindset
you know business opportunity space
behind tony robbins wow
he then goes around the country and the
world for 26 years heather 26 years
teaching people how to do this okay
about five years into this journey
somebody claims they go there's no way
anybody else can do this
you did that in that book and you did
that in the l.a times thing because you
are robert g allen you are special
and so robert gielen says all right i'm
going to go write another book so he
goes to write another book it's called
the challenge where what he does is he
goes to st louis and he pulls five
people out of the unemployment line this
is a real story wow and he turns them
into real estate investors in 30 days
they all have 50 000 in their pocket at
the end of 90 days never to see the
unemployment line ever again okay
wow so he continues his journey right
that's five years into his 26 year
travel around the world
and after 26 years
finally
he comes into my world comes into my
orbit
i land a tv show
and i
were set to start filming about a week
later
and i get a call from a guy his name is
tim and tim it runs a mastermind it's
all about educators being better
educators and he goes pace i really need
you to come and and speak on stage about
what you're doing with your people and
how you're providing so much value for
free all the time
and i go no i i can't tim we're starting
filming for season one it's like the
first day of school i've already got my
outfit picked out my backpack is brand
new i got my lunch box dude i'm freaking
geared up and ready to film a tv show
and he goes well you know um just in
case
here's the link to the site so you can
see the addre the the dates and you can
see who's speaking mm-hmm
oh my gosh heather i
freaking click on this link who's
speaking at this event
he is
robert g allen yeah
so i called jamil who's my my co-star on
the tv show i go bro we're calling in
sick on the first day of school i'm
telling you we are going to
key west florida i have to meet this guy
so we call a e we call in sick for our
first day of filming we push it back a
week so i can go and meet my hero robert
g allen mm-hmm
and he says i'm sorry not he says but we
fly in there and i get to the event and
i'm looking around for robert g allen
i'm looking around i'm looking around
and i then go out in the hallway and i
can see
his back turned to me and i know it's
him because he's i've been a hero of
mine for 20 something years
and i go up to him and i tap him on the
shoulder and he turns around i reach my
hand out
and i go mr allen and he turns around
and he says mr morby
yeah
wow what right so like my hero i meet my
hero and we get into this really
in-depth conversation and i said wow you
know who i am and he said
you are doing what i wish i did when i
started
and i said well what do you mean and he
went into this whole story heather this
is ties back into what you brought up
he says i taught around the world for 26
years millions and millions of people
heard me from stage on tv every medium
you can imagine
and i found out that 99 of people fail
not because of the strategies the
tactics the how
they fail because of their mindset and
their inability to what you just said
just press record
and he's like i now have a dedicated
mission to solve that one percent that
that remaining like little bit that
really will make everything else work
for everybody it's the mindset
and that is what you know you give
everything for away for free for the the
how the strategics the tactical the the
tangible get this camera turn it this
way get this light turn it on this thing
do all those kind of things
but what i love about you guys is like a
lot of the things that my team has
learned from you because i have a
handful of people on a on our media team
our team has solved a lot of their
mindset issues because of what you guys
have provided to our team as well and so
think about that a man that traveled
around the world for 26 years that took
on the biggest challenges and the la
times took him 26 years to figure out
what you guys are focusing on right now
in your business is solving people's
mindset problems
wow that's incredible and
you know what i even when i think about
just even personal brand in general
people are scared to even just put
themselves out there like why is that
scared
why is that
really good question pace i would think
one of the things i think is because
especially when i think about our
generation and generations before that
um we only when you think about like
maybe your dad had a video camera and he
would video at like thanksgiving or
christmas it was a giant thing or maybe
on a family vacation but it wasn't as
accessible as it is right now and you
were able to
i would think have more of a
more of a private life and people are
scared to put their private life out on
the internet and my thing is is you know
your personal brand doesn't actually
have to be it can it you can only share
what you want to share you don't
actually have to share everything and
what i think that you do so well is that
you know i feel like i know you because
you share elements of your life but i
don't know the intricacies of your
family i don't know you know i know your
daughter's name but i don't know her
personality on a you know like an auntie
level like there's these pieces of it
and so i feel like people think well if
i have to start sharing my personal
brand one
i think they actually might not be as
good as they claim to be so they're
scared that they actually don't know
what they're talking about and two
they're afraid to actually put
themselves out there because we've grown
up always being judged we've grown up
you know high school had its clicks and
if you there's just even like you said
with your wife there's those pieces of
elements of well do i do i think i'm
better than other people am i trying to
put myself out there in a way that um
seems prideful um i know you know i come
from a a faith-based background and i
know in in the church specifically it's
like no humble yourself don't raise
yourself and it's like actually i'm
raising for the kingdom i'm a woman of
faith and i i'm raising this for for to
bring light into the world and not
darkness and so i think that people
really struggle with those things and
they've not actually been presented with
how to grow like how do you do this how
do you grow it and and i think that's
one of the things that you do so well is
you just give it away you just i i love
what you said um and i think part of
that too is like there are people that
um have it this imposter syndrome
where they're like well i don't have all
the knowledge right i don't have all the
things i just know a little bit about
what i'm talking about and i i would
argue with them
when people walk into a library they
don't need all the library
they need one chapter of one book right
now really good wow
as long as you're only one chapter ahead
of one other person you have a
tremendous amount of value for them and
the one thing that i show people is this
um
i don't know if i can screen share in
here can i you can yeah but i love
streaming by the way
yeah
you can share screen and then walk
through it for the audio crowd okay cool
so here's what i'm here's what we're
looking at if it will did it pop up for
you here we go so youtube youtube if
you're watching over on youtube podcast
listeners you can see what price has up
but we'll walk you through uh we'll walk
you through this uh vocally as well so
there's two lines basically the first
line is called the observed line and
it's multiple squares that over time
those squares do not grow they stay at
the same exact level for basically
there's 10 of them and then there's the
practice line where as you practice and
you do the thing those squares grow it's
like a bar graph right that grows like
stairs
and so i look at this and a picture
paints
a thousand words
and i look at this and i'm like man
what people need
more than anything is just that next
step
they don't need the whole library of
knowledge they just need the next step
so when people think about like well i'm
not the hot shot and i'm not the person
that knows all the answers and i'm not
the this and i'm not that okay but you
did figure out
one step more than the person that's
right behind you and if you truly have a
community mindset you need to be turning
around and not leaving those people in
the dust your content should be allowing
them to get into chapter one of their
own life
and so
i think that's where i overcame that
fear of my own is like i'm not talking
to the person that is a billionaire i'm
talking to the person that's sitting
there and i'm telling you heather you
know this as well as i do
the majority of people 90 of people are
sitting there saying i need something
more and i wish somebody would highlight
the path that i should walk on and so
guys is it if there's a dark path right
you're thinking think about this there's
a dark path you're in the middle of the
wilderness you don't know you know the
path is there right just like how
they're saying turn on your your camera
it's content's going to bring you money
content is going to bring you business
opportunities content's going to do all
these things for you it's like okay i
know the path is there
but if somebody is so good and giving
you high level instruction typically
that means that somebody's standing at
the end of the path with a flashlight
and it's so far away from you that it's
dim
are you going to follow down that
pathway
no because i don't know how to get from
you
or from myself to where that dim light
is but if somebody's standing right in
front of you that light is so dang
bright and they just go here follow me
you it's better for you it's actually
better for you and better for your
audience for you not to be
light years ahead of them it's better
for you to be just one step ahead of
them or one chapter ahead of them and
once i realize that to be a true
statement oh my gosh it lit my passion
on fire because now i knew who i was
speaking to i was speaking to an earlier
younger more naive version of myself
so good i uh the way i like to put that
into words is um i tell people because
that expert piece is like the piece that
holds people back when they're
developing their personal brand and i
say i want you to develop yourself as a
leader a leader can still mess up a
leader still is developing a leader is
still someone who is moving forward but
they're but they are leading people and
so if you can just say actually instead
of saying i'm the expert of this i'm
just leading myself in learning this and
i want to bring you along the journey or
can you be a mentor can you be a best
friend in my homeschool content you know
i'm not a homeschool expert i've just
read all the books and done all the
blogs and homeschooled my kids for seven
and a half years so i have like and it's
not an expert but it's just like i'm
just a mentor along the journey to the
moms and dads who are just a step behind
trying to figure this thing out how do i
do this with work and family and my kids
are different and my kids are all
different ages and all those things so i
love how you said you actually you don't
have to be an expert you just need to
teach someone the next chapter one of
the things i think you do so well too in
your content and advice you give to
other people who are getting into the
space of developing personal brand is
the idea that the more real that you are
the stronger your content is i want to
talk about this a little bit because
this is the part where i i always say i
want to take like a hammer to people's
perfection and be like you don't have to
be perfect i want to just like no the
realness the the experiences the
embarrassments that actually is the
connection that people have have you
experienced that in your content yeah i
had an editor on my team when i first
started hiring people for my team and
you know my content started making money
i was like oh dang i can hire people
so i hired an editor and he would cut
out all my hymns and my haws and my
pauses and my uh
you know all that kind of stuff and i
was like
what man what's going on with my con
actually it wasn't me was somebody
reached out to me and they were like
dude what happened to the life of your
videos
and i was like i don't know and i went
back and i watched i go holy crap like
i'm not even myself right now i pause i
stutter i screw up my words i have to
backtrack and correct the things that
i'm saying and for me i could i was
lucky to see that in my journey
is that the perfect the perfect
thing that my editor was going for
actually took the life out of my videos
and it didn't show who i really was and
so i'm glad i learned that early on
um and now i when i have editors i'm
like do not
over edit my videos i'd rather it be a
little bit longer than us trying to
shoot for some perfect model the perfect
model is my genuine self
wow and i think one of the reasons pace
just from watching your content also i
am a pace morby fan uh we put pace morby
up on our tv you're part of our
homeschool curriculum pace because we're
learning about real estate i feel bad
because you guys watch that podcast and
i cussed on that podcast and i found out
later that your kid i was like no
it's all right my kids are okay uh i
think one of the things i love is it
really just feels like there's a camera
in your office like we're hanging out
with pace morby in his office while he's
talking to people on consultations
talking to sellers and and to me that is
the realness and like you said the
embarrassing things like i think it's
fun when you when you compare what you
do for tv versus what you can do for
youtube i'm sure there's a difference in
how you're able to present yourself
on camera is that correct
yeah you know this is let's get real
here because nobody from a e is going to
watch this so um let's hope not what's
funny is like my four-hour live my boss
his name is brad he's like the head of
the the network at amy he comes into my
zooms to like learn how to comp and
stuff because it actually helps him
produce better television which is great
yeah so maybe he'll watch this who knows
but um
what i if you gave me an opportunity to
be on tv or
on youtube and i could only choose one
which one am i choosing
i hope youtube not it's not even a
question it's not even close to a
question in fact
i um have learned certain things from
doing tv about like the production and
behind the scenes and stuff like that to
be a little bit more efficient but to be
honest with you
um i look at the tr not only the trend
but the ability for me to be exactly who
i am on youtube whereas on tv they're
trying to create this perfect model of
me and it's like this cardboard cut out
and it's like i i watch the show and i
go
that's not entirely who i am it's like
you guys are trying to tell a story
that's not exactly who i am
so youtube also has the ability to reach
the masses
people are kind of going away from cable
and all that kind of stuff
i get to do exactly what i want i get to
talk about what i want and i get to
create opportunities for myself if i if
i broke down what my business was and
what i make on youtube people i'd be
happy to get into that if we ever had
any time to do that or maybe we do
another episode
you would be flabbergasted at how
powerful youtube really is
the views are one thing it's like the
views are great and people are like oh
how many views views do i need to have
to be able to make enough money on i'm
like
if you only knew what really goes on
behind youtube you would be blown away
so all day long youtube is where it's at
i get to be myself i get to attract my
authentic audience
um and in that i know this is not the
question you asked but i just
i know we have condensed times i want to
give your audience things that i wish i
knew
i look at people like graham stefan
andre jic meet kevin people in my real
estate space that have three four five
million subscribers on youtube
and i'm like man when i i don't wanna
start youtube because a million two
million three million subscribers man
that's going to take me so long guys
first and foremost
i
make
so much money from youtube
when i was at 20 000 subscribers and
how do i make money people send me real
estate deals people send me affiliate
type of thing opportunities i
do brand deals right there's so many
things in that
people have given me ownership in
businesses because i have a 20 000
person youtube channel it's four times
five times bigger than that now
but even at that level there is millions
of dollars in real estate or not real
estate but in um youtube if you just be
your freaking self and turn on the
camera
yeah we teach the iceberg effect i love
that we have so many similar pieces and
i'm like yes because you're real pace
and you're really doing this and i love
bringing
real authentic creators who are in this
space and for us it's the iceberg where
like youtube's just the top of the
entire iceberg that's underneath like
all you see on the surface is this but
underneath that is why personal brand
matters that's why going all in you know
uh jay-z has the quote i'm not a
businessman i'm a business
man and that to me is like that's what i
want people to see for 2022 and beyond
is that your brand you the person
creating the content is going to be so
much more valuable as you just keep
going as you keep going and actually
point number four is actually commit to
it and this is something i wanted to to
really lean into especially with you
pace because when i look at um you did
this video because again i am do you
have like a i'm not in the sub too but
do you have like a youtube uh name are
they like the morbis or like what's the
name of like the youtube community
that's what i'm in um
anyways side note but my home they're my
homies that's what you're homie okay i'm
a homie guys i get to be a homie i feel
uh honored okay but what
when you did this one where you broke
down your businesses and i thought man
if there's one thing i want to make sure
that pace gets to talk about on this
podcast because you are
a um you are a man that has literally
like so many businesses you're pulled in
so many different directions you're
running a tv show you're running
multi-million dollar deals you're doing
all these things but you're committed to
doing this and you've stayed committed
to doing this can you just speak a
little bit to the person who feels like
um i don't even like to say this but
i'll say it they're quote unquote too
busy because i don't think anyone's too
busy i think it's where you put your
priorities and your commitments right
but but for the person that has that
mindset still i don't know when i'm
going to be able to do this how am i
going to be able to make this happen my
life's already crazy i've got the kids
and the bills and the business and all
those things
how do you commit to this and why are
you committing to this for the long haul
i love that i'm going to share one more
image if you don't mind this just walk
through it for for the audio
sorry audio listeners you guys are going
to be like this was our worst guess we
hate this guy he didn't he didn't help
us out at all
no if you like this pace is getting that
up make sure you comment down below uh
tell me your aha moment so far that pace
has given you in this episode if you're
watching on youtube and leave a review
over on apple podcast and let us know if
you liked this episode from pace all
right we've got the visual up pace walk
us through i love this visual walk us
through what we're seeing this strikes
fear in so many people's minds so
essentially what it is is there's an
image that says this might seem scary
and it's a it's a basically a
set of stairs a flight of stairs and
it's showing
you know taking that first step might
seem scary right that's the thing that
most people are afraid of but what is
actually scary is the image below it
which is now two flights of stairs
showing you on step one today and then
in a year from now still on step one
that truly is the biggest fear that i
have is not reaching my biggest
potential and i tell people all the time
my biggest my biggest thing is
i don't mind problems
i mind the same problems month in and
month out in fact i'm on a search to go
find the next set of problems so when i
first started it was like
pressing the record button oh my gosh
think about this okay
this is a weird thing and i know we're
limited how much time do you guys
usually do these i have eight more
minutes to my next eight more minutes
this whole story is gonna take 19
minutes guys so bear it down so i tell
this story to people that are like oh
i'm afraid of this or i'm afraid of that
like okay imagine this you're on your
deathbed
and you're about to die you've got all
these people around you it's the
hospital and you basically have like 30
seconds you can see your heart
monitor going down and down and down and
downing you're about to pass away
you've got your kids you got your loved
ones around you got the people that
worked with you everybody you love is
around and
in comes
somebody wearing all black kind of an
ominous figure you can't he's kind of a
faceless figure
they come in and they go hey pace hey
heather
i have this little vial of liquid that i
will let you drink
and it will give you one day of your
life back just one day of your life back
how much will you pay
me for this vial of liquid my answer and
my dying breath is going to be
everything i will give you everything
any money any dollar amount anything
that i have of any you know value other
than the people i love i will give you
all of it
and the ominous figure says okay great
here you go but here's the catch
you're going to drink this liquid it's
going to not give you an additional day
of your life back it's going to take you
to a random day of your life and you
have to relive every single moment the
exact way you lived it and just be a
passenger on the ride you're gonna smell
the same smells eat the same food wake
up at the same every little word out of
your mouth and the feelings the sun the
sun hitting your skin
kissing your spouse hugging your
children all of the good things
you can't do anything you can't change
anything
here's the catch and i go done okay
but it's random
and you go all the way back
to a point where you are looking at your
phone
and you're standing there inside of your
own brain watching as like a passenger
in your own life and you go uh i'll do
it tomorrow
and you get to watch yourself knowing
everything you know on your deathbed you
get to watch yourself doing this again
and you can't change anything
that is my biggest fear is looking at
these little things that people just
won't do like press the record button
post something on you like
youtube now has youtube live you don't
even need to edit anything like
literally you can just put something up
there right now
would you give up everything just to go
back to the day that you sat there and
go i'll do it tomorrow
and now you missed yourself actually
making progress and then what happens is
you start seeing the domino effect of
how it affected everybody that was
sitting around you at your on your
deathbed like how much better would
their lives have been if you would have
just taken that next stinking step
and so for me i have no fear anymore
because i just kind of think of those
types of things like what are the things
in my life that i'm i'm so fearful of
and i'm not taking action on and would i
be okay watching myself like a fly on
the wall sitting there watching myself
procrastinate and push those off to the
next day
probably not and so i i actually posted
a youtube video three four days ago that
it was so clunky
and my team was like hey do you want us
to edit that i was like no it's perfect
i i'm like
i'm feeling it i'm feeling that whole uh
man when i say like commit to it it's so
powerful and that to me i love that you
said that at the end pace because it
doesn't have to be perfect you just have
to commit to it you have progress over
perfection all day long give me progress
don't ever give me perfection in fact um
last thing i'll say and i don't know if
heather wants to wrap this up she
probably is bothered because i just want
to talk and hang out with her but
um i was driving around the country in
texas the other day and a couple months
ago
and my videographer bobby was in the
driver's seat i was in the back seat in
jamil my co-star was in you know
passenger seat bobby
leans over and he asked me hey pace why
do you think
you are more successful than other
people or what is it about you that
makes you more successful and i go i
don't know man maybe it was like my
parents maybe like i just love to you
know you know my parents just taught me
to be a good guy i don't know man and
then i really thought about it i go oh i
know i know the answer
i know the answer i literally sound so
cliche but the older you get and the
more experience you get you realize that
cliche things are cliche for a reason
i said dude i literally don't even think
about the destination ever i literally
just think about how much more fun can i
have every day solving new problems and
how much more fun can i have hanging out
with other people that are solving those
same problems and we just collaborate
all day long it's like i'm in high
school all over again every single day
and i wake up energized excited
committed because i get to hang out with
a really cool group of people like
that's why i love hanging out with you
heather you and i are doing the same
thing we get to talk about the same
stuff
so
people if you guys are out there and
you're not turning the camera on and
you're not building your personal brand
i would say how many
successful youtubers or how many
successful content creators are in your
immediate social network the answer is
probably zero and you guys aren't
spending time getting to know people in
facebook groups or spending time getting
to know people in the youtube comments
on you know think media's youtube
channel that's where i would go i've
made friends there i have i collaborate
with people in video actually ryan
pineda what's funny is ryan pineda will
and i will sometimes see each other in
your guys's comments on think media and
we're like commenting on these stuff
each other's stuff
i freaking love this and i love what you
guys are doing you you and sean are
truly some of my heroes and you have
made me and my 900 employees now
millions and millions of dollars of
revenue because you guys taught us how
to get over the fear and how to actually
go and make progress in our lives
oh my goodness i there's no better way
to end that face that was incredible
thank you so much for your time um i
know that you could have been in a
hundred different places literally pace
more we actually could be in a hundred
different places right now and you chose
to be here on the think media podcast i
want to honor you pace and just say
thank you for showing others the path
thank you for being um just a righteous
man who's gonna step out and make this
thing happen and to bring other people
along with you thank you for being
someone who will invest your time into
what we're doing here and your kind
words
i'm so honored to have you on and i i
hope that everyone listening right now
goes and follows pace not even just for
the content of figuring out how he's
doing personal brand but because this
man is a genius when it comes to
understand real estate creative finance
and if you want to be in the coolest
community ever it actually is pace's
community so i want to make sure you go
over and follow him on youtube and on
instagram and pace thank you so much for
your time today it really means the
world to me that you would spend it with
us here at the think media podcast thank
you appreciate you
well i hope you got value out of this
episode and if you want us to interview
other entrepreneurs like pace let us
know in the comments down on youtube who
else we should bring here on the show
and if you've not yet rated and reviewed
the podcast in whatever country you're
in and wherever you listen to it you can
do this over on apple itunes and we love
to be able to bring some of our think
fam here on the show to say thank you
for leaving that review today's review
comes from one of our international
listeners jessica she said the best
podcast for youtube creators i love the
last episode with tips and principles
for success from the bible so much
wisdom thank you so much think media
well thank you jessica for listening in
and being a part of our think media
community we're so incredibly grateful
that you tune in every single week for
these episodes and thank you for rating
and reviewing the show if you've not yet
shared this with a friend maybe you know
someone who's in the real estate space
or as a service provider who needs to
listen to this episode where pace dives
into all about growing their personal
brand i know you know someone so share
this episode with them thank you so much
for being a part of what we're doing
here at think media it means the world
to us that you are here on this journey
with us to grow your influence on
youtube and beyond thanks much for
listening and we'll catch you in the
next episode bye
[Music]